Prof: Okay,
let me start in.
This lecture is about national
security,
and it's about the conflict
that's involved during the
twentieth century between
national security and
environmental quality and human
health.
So I want to explore that,
because so much money in the
world is spent on national
security,
and it has the potential to
invade individual rights,
to diminish personal freedom,
to diminish privacy.
At the same time,
it has the potential to
concentrate power and authority
among elites,
political elites,
wealthy elites,
technical elites,
so that it's threatening to
democratic participation and
policy making in a variety of
ways.
And as we move through the
course,
you'll find that secrecy is not
just an issue that we need to
figure out how to manage better
in the public sector relative to
classified information,
and this is the topic of
today's session.
But it's also a critical issue
in the private sector.
The growing use of confidential
business information,
the growing obscurity of
product ingredients as
globalized markets cause
products and services to cross
national borders without any
clear identity about components
or potential effects.
So national security and
environmental quality.
I want you to think about this
case and other cases that we
deal with as a problem of
managing intelligence.
I'm not meaning to imply that
other people are not
intelligent,
I'm meaning to hopefully get
you to think about the idea of a
legal system that would produce
a public that was literate and
capable of understanding the
quality of the environment
around them,
what's threatening and what's
not, so that potentially they
could manage their exposure to
chemicals,
they could manage the effect of
human behavior on a variety of
environmental issues,
such as endangered species.
So the purpose for the title of
my book that I'm having you
read, you poor things,
is the idea of thinking about
the origin of knowledge.
You know, where do we get the
information?
Where do we get the data?
Where do we get the knowledge?
Who produces it?
And what we'll see today is
that knowledge about the
environmental effects of
national security are produced
predominately by the Defense
Department.
They control sites,
they control the technology in
weaponry and weapon delivery
systems,
making it extremely difficult
for the public to understand
really what the dangers might
be.
Where does the knowledge flow?
Is it intelligible?
Is it understood?
The distinction between is it
intelligible and is it
understood is really critical.
It involves literacy,
it involves educational
background, technical
competence.
And who owns it?
This is really a key question
for law.
You can think about this in
terms of it being an
intellectual property right
question.
Should the public own it?
Should the government be able
to keep the knowledge from the
public?
Should the private sector be
allowed to own it,
and should they be allowed to
keep knowledge from the public?
So think about it as a problem
of understanding production and
flow of knowledge.
Because environmental quality
is always going to be elusive
until we create a public that
really is far more intelligent,
so to speak,
understanding,
than it currently is.
So what are the purposes of
secrecy?
I'm kind of fascinated by the
growing classification of
information in the public
sector.
So that in U.S.
history, never before has the
government been classifying more
information than it is today.
You know, at the same time,
there's a very interesting
cultural change that we're
witnessing in your generation
related to Facebook.
I mean, I have never seen a
generation be so interested in
revealing secrets or information
about themselves as your
generation is.
So it's a disconnect in a way
between government policy and
what's going on in social
circles among younger
generations.
How do terror and warfare
depend upon secrecy?
When does secrecy threaten
national security?
When is secrecy necessary for
And how is it related to
individual rights?
These are key questions that I
hope you'll keep in mind as we
move through this lecture today.
There are common scripts in
environmental history,
no matter whether or not you
consider this case or the case
of endangered species,
the case of managing water
quality,
managing sustainable
agriculture.
Who knew about the problem?
Who knew about contaminants in
this case?
When did they know?
When did they inform the public?
And what did they do about the
problem?
These are critical questions,
and secrecy is a central
component of all of them.
So that the history that I want
to go through today is really
one that is very brief.
It only spans the period
between 1944 and 1963.
So in this period,
the atomic weapons,
the first atomic weapons were
designed and tested,
the first one at Los Alamos in
New Mexico in 1945,
followed by two uses of atomic
weapons,
the only two aggressive uses in
world history.
One on Hiroshima and the other
on Nagasaki,
killing hundreds of thousands
of people and resulting in
injuries and death,
inheritable mutations that have
affected generations of
Japanese.
So this compressed period is
really quite striking.
Now, why in the world would we
be talking about this issue,
which seems so old now,
it's part of the Cold War,
in a class on current
environmental law and policy?
Well, I'll tell you a bit of a
story.
In 2003, I was in the Beinecke
Rare Book Library.
And I don't know if you have
visited the Beinecke Library,
but it really is a remarkable
place.
It's got a wonderful,
rich store of information,
especially on the American
West.
But I found out just by surfing
the net that they also have all
of Rachel Carson's original
research material.
Now, Rachel Carson wrote
"Silent Spring"
and "The Sea Around
Us" and a number of other
books,
and is rather famous in
environmental history,
particularly for her work
trying to get the public to wake
up about the dangers of
pesticides,
especially related to wildlife
because she was a wildlife
biologist working for the Fish
and Wildlife Service.
Well it turns out that all of
her original research materials,
including about 120 boxes of
material, are stored in the
basement of Beinecke Library.
So going through those,
as I was trying to understand
the history of pesticides,
I found one file that was on
nuclear weapons testing.
And that file was incredibly
dense.
And as she conducted her
research, by the way,
it's very different than what
we do today when our research is
almost all electronic.
She would hand copy material,
there were no copy machines
that she had access to at that
point in time.
And then she would write notes,
little side notes interpreting
it as she went along.
So going through this,
I realized that all of her work
on pesticides where she wondered
what happened to them once they
were released.
Where they went,
how did they make their way
into the soil?
Why were wildlife,
the canaries in the mine in a
sense, what were the wildlife
telling us about human hazards
and human risk?
And what was wrong with current
law and policy that would allow
that kind of release and
non-accountability on the part
of the private sector?
So she learned that way of
thinking,
that narrative logic,
she learned that,
not by studying pesticides,
by looking at the history of
the Atomic Energy Commission in
the 1950s and how they came to
understand radionuclides and
what happened to them and the
kind of threat they posed to
water quality,
to air quality,
how they got into wildlife,
how they got into human tissue.
So this is a story of today.
So the idea that the success in
any of these cases is dependent
upon very high quality science
is a very important idea.
And remember what I said the
other day,
that perhaps ninety-five
percent of the science in the
field of environmental science
is conducted in the private
sector,
it never sees the light of day.
Well in this case,
this is probably the best
example of state science at an
enormous scale.
The Atomic Energy Commission
had an unlimited budget,
they had unlimited authority,
and they had unlimited capacity
to tell a story about danger and
the importance of pursuing
atomic weapons development in
order to protect national
security.
So this time span just gives
you the number of tests per year
between 1945,
or actually,
the number of explosions,
1945 and 1962.
In 1963, President Kennedy
worked with the Soviets to pass
the Limited Test Ban Treaty.
And since that time,
atmospheric testing has been
severely limited.
Known nuclear tests worldwide
between '45 and '96,
roughly about 2,000,
maybe about 2,400.
After 1963, the majority of
tests, or the number of tests
actually went up.
But most of them went
underground.
So underground testing is
allowed, and we'll see later on
in the lecture that there have
been certain parts of the world,
it's been agreed among nations
that have this nuclear capacity
to avoid testing.
So outer space is now off
limits.
Testing in the South Pacific is
now off limits because it was
the site of many highly intense
tests of hydrogen bombs.
And also, testing on the poles
is restricted by international
agreement.
So this was a very limited
period of time,
and many people don't
understand where these tests
were conducted.
Some in the South Atlantic,
some in Mississippi,
some in Japan,
New Mexico, the Pacific Ocean,
the Nevada Test Site,
Johnson Island,
Christmas Island,
Eniwetok and Bikini,
which are part of the Marshall
Islands in the Pacific.
I'll be speaking more about
this and show you some film
clips on next Tuesday when we
reconvene.
One interesting aspect of this
history was the behavior of
Klaus Fuchs,
who was a theoretical scientist
working at Los Alamos on the
development of the first weapon,
the first atomic bomb,
during what is known as the
Manhattan Project.
And he had access to top-secret
material.
A very highly skilled
physicist, and he passed most of
what he knew on to the Soviets
in the late 1940s.
So he was tried and convicted
of espionage in Britain in the
1950s, and he served nine years
out of a fourteen-year sentence.
This is fascinating to me.
Think about the nature of the
sanction here.
So that the Soviets gained
their understanding of how the
U.S.
produced nuclear weapons and
gained an understanding of what
our strategy was,
how we were testing it,
how we were monitoring the
effects,
what the intensity of the
radiation was.
And the man serves only nine
years in prison.
The lesson is kind of curious.
Most secrets have very short
lives, and the more valuable
they are, the more limited is
their life.
So I think about the idea of
creating a secret as creating a
property right.
And so it creates a property
right and its value is dependent
on many aspects of its
character, and we'll explore
that as we move through.
The power of explosions on the
Bikini Atoll in the South
Pacific is something to take
note of.
Next Tuesday,
we'll come back to this story,
where the Bikini Islanders were
removed from their island
through negotiation and the use
of eminent domain.
And then the U.S.
proceeded to test about
twenty-five,
twenty-six different nuclear
weapons,
including the Bravo Test in
1954 that I'll show you a clip
of,
which was one of the largest
bombs ever exploded by the U.S.
in the atmosphere.
The Atomic Energy Commission
created what they called Project
Gabriel that evolved to be
called Project Sunshine--that
lasted between 1949 and 1961.
So Project Sunshine became
famous, and it was the
collection of scientists in the
government working with the
Atomic Energy Commission based
predominately at the University
of Chicago and Columbia
University,
the Lamont Laboratories.
So scientists were given
virtually unlimited funds to
conduct research that would help
the Atomic Energy Commission
understand the power of their
different weapons.
And there were some 200
different types of nuclear
weapons eventually that were
designed.
And some so large that they had
to redesign aircraft in order to
handle the weight,
and others so small that they
could be tactically carried in a
suitcase and be used under field
conditions that were very
difficult.
Different delivery mechanisms,
delivery by aircraft,
delivery by missile,
delivery by artillery,
delivery by suitcase,
so that a variety of different
types of bombs of different
strengths were designed for
different types of warfare.
So the Sunshine scientists
really ramped up in the early
1950s.
And what's interesting is the
way that they thought about
environmental science.
They wondered what happened to
the radionuclides.
Where do they go when a bomb
explodes, what happens?
Well, dust particles get blown
up into the atmosphere.
If you drop a bomb in shallow
water,
it will take the material on
the bottom of the water and will
take the fish and it will
basically blow everything up and
the coral up into the
atmosphere.
It will also kill any birds
that are in close proximity.
So every test has a story about
birds raining from the sky,
on fire.
It will also cause a pattern of
movement in the atmosphere that
depends very much upon climate
and wind conditions.
And the power of the bomb
determines how high up into the
atmosphere the particles get.
So dozens and dozens of
different nuclides were created,
some of which had never been
recognized before.
So trying to figure this out,
one of the first things they
did was they set up a monitoring
system.
That made sense.
If you want to figure out where
something is going,
you set up a monitoring system.
In this case,
it was rather simplistic,
around the Nevada Test Site
north of Las Vegas,
about sixty-five miles.
And people used to cluster on
tops of the casinos and the
hotels in the evening to watch
the bombs explode,
or get up really early in the
morning to watch the bombs
explode,
highly visible,
given the clear climate.
So they set up their monitors
and they presumed that they had
captured the dispersal of
radiation.
And then they began to get
reports.
Reports came in from different
parts of the country,
some in North Dakota from
people that were mining for
uranium that had carried Geiger
counters.
And one miner was telling a
story where he was eating dinner
at his campfire with his Geiger
counter that he forgot to turn
off.
And the Geiger counter started
to spit back at him,
<<stuttering
noise>>.
And he said,
"Oh boy,
you know, I've got to have this
thing serviced.
It must be out of tune,
it must be detecting something
that is not there."
So he took it in to have it
serviced and found out that it
was actually in great tune,
didn't need to be recalibrated.
He went back to his site and it
happened again.
So he realized gradually that
something was going on in the
atmosphere.
It wasn't measuring anything in
the mine or in nearby rock
because it normally in that
place would be silent.
He was picking up radionuclides
that were raining down in North
Dakota.
Polaroid became important in
the process of understanding the
distribution,
Polaroid Film Company,
because its film was found to
be exposed when it arrived at
doctors' offices and hospitals
in different parts of the world.
And at that point in time,
they used to put the Polaroid
film, the eight-and-a-half by
eleven sheets,
into boxes.
And then they would pack the
boxes, you know,
not with these Styrofoam
kernels that we use today that
will never go away.
But instead,
they used to pack it with
cornhusks.
So gradually,
they figured it out because
they could see in some cases the
image of the cornhusk on top of
the film matching directly.
So what was happening?
Well, the radionuclides were
intersecting a cloud,
they were raining down,
in this case in the Midwestern
part of the United States,
where the box had been packed.
And the cornhusks were exposing
the film, because they had
absorbed the radionuclides.
So they realized gradually that
their donut 200 miles in
diameter around Las Vegas was
completely inappropriate to
capture the scale of this
problem.
This is a very important lesson
in environmental science and
environmental policy.
It's like the analogy of the
drunk leaning on a light post
looking for his car keys.
Why is he looking under the
light post?
That's because that's where the
light is.
So that there are many,
many different stories about
the failure of environmental
science and the ineffectiveness
of environmental law that flow
from this problem of
misunderstanding the need for a
very sensitive sampling design.
In this case,
the Stokes test in 1957 put
radionuclides into the
atmosphere, but they started
moving at different directions
at different altitudes.
Ooh, there's an interesting
idea, that's novel.
No one thought about that
before.
So here, the dashed line at the
bottom is moving at 30,000 feet,
and it just nicks the southeast
side of Idaho.
Whereas the dust at 10,000 feet
shoots all the way up to
Montana.
Then it arcs up over southern
Canada, comes back over the
Great Lakes.
Then you see that arc of the
dashed line coming right down
across Lake Champlain on the New
York-Vermont border,
the Massachusetts-New York
border, and then the Connecticut
border.
Well that's pretty interesting.
Another test that they followed
created dust clouds that again
were driven by weather patterns.
And you see in this case that
at 30,000 feet,
one swirled around Texas for
about a week.
Another one swooped all the way
at 20,000 feet down into
Florida,
and probably would have been
detected if they had rainstorms
in Florida at the time of the
dust cloud that got there,
that would have been detectable
in oranges,
in orange juice,
and in orange oils.
So that crops were being
threatened and exposed in a
variety of different ways that
were being driven by weather
patterns.
And we all know that even
today, it's hard to predict what
the weather's going to be within
thirty-six hours in many parts
of the country.
So that the state of weather
forecasting back at this time
was quite primitive.
So that basically told these
scientists, and then again,
I can just imagine what they
were doing, sitting across the
table looking at each other.
How are we going to manage this?
What's going to happen if the
public understands this?
How are we going to maintain
our political support for the
weapons testing program so that
we can keep on building these
weapons to contain the Soviets
or to strike fear into their
hearts?
Following their policy of
deterrence,
the bigger the bomb,
the less likely we are to be
attacked by other nations that
would understand that an attack
would be simply suicide.
Well, here is a chart,
which is an amalgamation of
different bomb blasts and the
pathways that they took,
and the darkest areas are areas
that received the highest doses
of radiation.
And these nuclides have
half-lives that vary between
roughly three to four weeks up
to forty, fifty,
a hundred years.
So that if you went to the
center of the country in Iowa
and you took tests of the soil,
you could still detect many of
these radionuclides in the soil.
And they are transferable from
soil to crops and up to fruits.
So that this patchiness and
fallout was eventually
recognized by the Atomic Energy
Commission in the mid-1950s.
And gradually,
once this information was
declassified in the early 1990s,
and the only reason I'm telling
you this story is because most
of this knowledge was eventually
declassified.
I couldn't be here,
which is kind of an interesting
thought,
I couldn't be here right now
telling you this story had the
declassification process not
occurred under the Clinton
Administration.
Once they realized that the
Atomic Energy Commission had
kept all this information from
the public,
when they really had no
national security logic to do
so.
So here is a map of the United
States constructed by the
National Cancer Institute in the
late 1990s,
that took the dose estimates
that they got from the soils,
because they could back
calculate the concentrations
from existing concentrations,
knowing the decay rate of
different nuclides.
And they developed this map of
expected doses.
And then the Cancer Institute
started asking questions,
because they understood the
dose-response relationship for
radiation and these nuclides is
really pretty clear.
This not like you have to drink
10,000 cans of diet soda to
absorb enough saccharine to
elevate your cancer risk a
little bit.
This is a science that evolved
in the 1950s largely because of
the importance to the military
that understood the
dose-response relationship quite
clearly.
But understanding a
dose-response relationship,
meaning, let's see,
the best way to explain
dose-response relationship if
it's not familiar to you,
especially for college
students, is to think about a
six-pack of beer.
So you get a six-pack of beer,
you have one beer.
You might feel a little bit of
it.
You have two beers within
fifteen minutes.
I know you'd never do that.
You have three beers within
twenty minutes.
You have six beers within an
hour so that the effect that you
feel,
the effect on your body,
depends upon the dose and the
concentration that you're
actually circulating in your
system.
So they understood this
relationship with great clarity
with respect to these
radionuclides,
so that the cancer estimates
really are quite robust.
One interesting thing is that
if you look at the pattern of
testing that really,
it peaked in the late 1950s so
that you see this is
radionuclides in rainwater.
And then there was an agreement
not to test for a period of two
years.
And you see that the rainwater
levels declined.
It's in the rainwater.
Hmm, that's interesting.
If it's in the rainwater,
what does that mean for fish?
What does it mean for rivers?
What does it mean for parts of
the West that experience high
levels of snowpack?
Well, it means that snowpack,
for example,
Jackson, Wyoming a couple years
ago.
Jackson Hole,
Wyoming received more than 600
inches of snow in one year.
And in a matter of about a
month in the period between
April and late May,
you get basically warmer
weather melting all the snow.
So in this period of time you
get this rush,
you get this pulse of
radioactive water that moves
into a stream.
And lo and behold,
where could you test that?
Well, you could test that in
the supermarket.
Where?
In what supermarket?
In the salmon in supermarkets,
the trout in the supermarket.
Buying trout in the supermarket.
You could find these levels
increasing in the Columbia River
that goes by the Hanford uranium
enrichment plant,
plutonium enrichment plant in
the state of Washington.
So the water levels,
concentrations were going up
because the rainwater
concentrations were going up,
and the fish concentrations
were going up.
And also, people that were
drinking water out of wells that
were fed underground by the
aquifer from the Hanford area,
they were also being exposed.
The per capita dose was
calculated as well,
and you see the dip between
January of 1960 and late 1962
during the agreed cessation of
testing.
So this information was really
quite robust.
So Project Sunshine basically
pieced together this idea that
these nuclides were in global
circulation,
they were contaminating every
aspect of our environment,
and they were making their way
into humans,
and particularly they were
concerned about strontium-90,
because if you have a diet that
is low in calcium,
your body's going to absorb
more strontium-90 into your
bone.
Also, if you have a diet that's
low in iodine,
your thyroid is going to absorb
more iodine-131 than it normally
would.
So understanding this
relationship between calcium and
strontium-90 is very important,
because it eventually led to
calcium enrichment of breads,
of milk.
So the fortification program
really had its origination in
recommendations by the Atomic
Energy Commission.
So the public thought,
oh, we're just getting more
minerals in our diet.
Well, that must be a good
thing, the nutritionists must be
arguing that this makes a lot of
sense.
But in reality,
what was going on was that the
Atomic Energy Commission was
anxiously wringing its hands
recognizing that they've got to
figure out how to lower the dose
being experienced in the
population.
The population had no idea what
was going on.
So Project Sunshine scientists,
they eventually obtained 15,000
bodies,
dead bodies,
trying to understand the
distribution of these nuclides
throughout the world.
Bodies from New York,
San Francisco,
Houston, Japan,
India, South Africa.
Why from other nations?
Well, predominately because
they were worried about other
nations coming back and telling
the United States that we were
contaminating not only their
food supplies,
which was going to harm their
ability to trade products
internationally,
processed foods,
water, just about any kind of
crop you could think of,
as well as animals.
So that gradually over the
period between 1955 and 1960,
the Atomic Energy Commission
grew to really understand the
global distributional pattern
and how people in certain areas
of Latin America and tropical
areas were really experiencing
quite high levels of fallout.
Why would that be?
In tropical rainforests,
they experience intense
rainfall.
So that the rain was so high
that it would concentrate the
nuclides in some of the tropical
forest areas.
So permission to take the body
parts was never sought or
obtained.
Family members were never
consulted.
Bones were cleaned and packaged
in formalin.
And then they were crushed and
analyzed by laboratory
technicians at Columbia and
other prestigious U.S.
academic institutions.
And sometimes the bones were
pooled together.
Gradually they decided that
they were going to look for
geographic variability and they
were going to look for
age-related variability.
Because they were finding that
kids, for some reason,
were absorbing more of the
radionuclides,
especially strontium,
than adults were.
So why would that be?
Was it something about their
diet?
Was there something about their
physiology?
Well, it had to do with their
rate of growth of bone.
So kids are growing most
rapidly at what point in their
lives?
Well, from time of conception
roughly until the time of
thirteen.
But different organ systems and
different functions in the body
mature at different rates.
So stature, for example,
is quite linear,
although you get this really
serious growth curve in utero.
And then it goes up gradually,
gradually, and then more
steeply during the early teenage
years.
So you could figure out the
concentrations that were
correlated with these periods of
rapid growth and development.
So gradually,
these secrets started to leak
out.
And the U.S.
began to study fallout data.
And once the Soviets had
developed their own capacity to
make and test nuclear weapons,
the Atomic Energy Commission
had this great argument.
Well, there are nuclides in our
food supply and in our bodies,
it's not our fault.
Well, we take some
responsibility,
but it's the Soviets' fault.
The Soviets were actually
testing these weapons up in
Siberia.
And the Siberian radionuclides
tended to come down across
Alaska and across Canada and
into the Western and Midwestern
part of the U.S.,
so in threads that are similar
to the ones that I showed you
from the Nevada test site.
So the U.S.
was trying to at this point
desperately maintain public
support for continued testing,
in part because they were
wondering well,
what would happen if we did
have a nuclear war?
Where would the nuclides go?
And what would our capacity to
respond be?
So these were legitimate
national security concerns that
they were exploring.
So the U.S.
began to release some of its
information at the same time
that states started their own
testing programs.
So just like you find
variability in air pollution
today from motor vehicles,
depending upon climate and
where vehicle use is most
intense,
you find in this case states
being worried about specific
patterns of concentration in the
crops that they grow.
Vermont cheese,
for example,
or Midwestern grains or cattle
grazed in the Western U.S.
So Minnesota,
Vermont, and other states felt
like they were environmental
hotspots,
and that their corporations
were being hindered,
their capacity to trade
nationally and internationally
was being diminished.
The U.S.
finally started an open test of
milk for radioactivity in 1957,
twelve years after the
explosions began.
And Linus Pauling,
who won the Nobel Prize for his
work on nutrition,
particularly related to vitamin
C, came out with his conclusion
that the body really
discriminates against strontium
and favors calcium uptake if the
calcium levels were high enough.
That prompted the addition of
the calcium, as I was saying,
to milk, bread,
and animal feeds,
as well as fertilizers.
So this is quite curious.
The Surgeon General for the U.S.
denied that the fallout hazards
were serious in the New York
Times in 1959.
So there was really quite an
open public debate in the late
'50s, in part that surrounded
Eisenhower's campaign to become
president again in 1956.
And his competitor was his vice
president, Adlai Stevenson.
So Stevenson basically broke
the news that the Atomic Energy
Commission had been hiding this
information from the public.
And in his last-minute campaign
effort,
he claimed that there were
genetic hazards to future
generations,
risk of bone cancer,
and the inability to conduct
medical investigations.
Now, this is interesting.
So that there is exposure that
is universal,
everybody's exposed because
everybody eats.
That means that you really
don't have any opportunity for a
scientific control group that is
unexposed to figure out what the
long-term health effects might
be.
Thirteen Yale scientists,
including Arthur Galston of the
Biology Department,
who passed away just a few
years ago,
signed a statement endorsing
the views of Stevenson.
Stevenson lost,
Eisenhower became president
again.
And what was interesting about
it is that transcripts from his
conferences, his national
security team,
had been released in the late
1990s as well.
And Eisenhower eventually got
to the point where he was
telling his staff that the
levels of radionuclides in the
milk supply,
the buildup especially in
children's bones,
was unacceptable,
and something was going to have
to happen.
And that prompted him to be
more aggressive in trying to
negotiate with the Soviets to
create some sort of a treaty
that would reduce atmospheric
testing.
So I'm going to jump ahead here
so I don't run out of time.
The Atomic Energy Commission
also was found to have withheld
data recognizing that there were
these spikes in the New York
cities' milk supplies,
data that was collected just
prior to the election that they
understood posed a problem.
They held that until weeks
after the election.
So it's kind of curious that
milk became the standard for
trying to figure out where the
chemicals went,
especially powdered buttermilk,
because in its dehydrated form,
it was easy to send around the
country.
And this chart I think is also
interesting, because remember
that the Limited Test Ban Treaty
of 1963 really stopped the
testing cold.
And what you see is a gradual
decline in worldwide fallout,
represented by strontium-90 and
cesium-137 in milk.
So you see this gradual decline
because of the residency time in
the atmosphere,
so that these chemicals don't
all wash out like quickly after
the explosions.
They go into global circulation.
And there was great debate at
the time about the amount of
time that they stayed in the
atmosphere.
And the Atomic Energy
Commission was arguing,
don't worry about it.
They're going to stay in the
atmosphere for a long period of
time.
Why would they use that logic?
Well, they wanted the radiation
to dissipate so that by the time
the nuclides got down to the
ground that they wouldn't pose
such an intense radiation
threat.
Now, that's kind of an
interesting story.
So environmentalists and public
health advocates were arguing,
no, you don't understand this
pattern of deposition.
It's often more quickly that it
reaches the ground concentrated
in the higher intensity of
radiation.
So that this story played out
over the 1970s and 1980s until
gradually, you find 1995 it
really leveling off to what it
is today.
Curiously, you see the spike in
cesium-137 in 1987,1986,
1987.
Anybody have any idea what that
might be?
Student: Chernobyl.
Prof: Chernobyl.
Chernobyl released more
cesium-137 to the atmosphere
after the explosion,
where the dome of the building
blew off and there was a fire
that was uncontainable for a
period of weeks.
It spewed more radiation into
the atmosphere in the form of
cesium-137 than many of the
earlier atmospheric weapons
tests did.
So I began by telling you that
under conditions of secrecy,
the people that hold power over
the secret have great narrative
advantage.
They not only control the
search for the data,
they control its interpretation
and they control the story
that's told to the general
public.
And a couple of elements of
this story are kind of fun to
think about,
because we'll see these same
narratives evolve for
pesticides,
for plastics,
for a variety of different
environmental problems.
Is the problem human induced or
is it more important to worry
about natural sources?
Natural sources of radiation,
hmm.
So you see these comparisons
between the dose that you would
get by having a glass of milk or
having the diet of a child,
a comparison between that and
number of flights that you would
take across the United States.
And you probably know that you
get a measurable dose of
radiation when you're up in
aircraft.
So this comparison between
human-induced exposure compared
to natural exposure,
another good example of that
would be radon.
And in Connecticut,
we have a problem with radon
gas,
which is radioactive,
being emitted especially from
the kind of rock that we have
here,
and particularly along the
coastline heading east down here
along the Long Island Sound.
And my basement in my house,
for example,
we had a radon problem where
radon gas was not just
measurable, it was really quite
high.
So we had to figure out how to
remediate that.
You dig a hole in your basement
floor, you put a little fan and
a pipe in, and you get rid of
it.
If you don't do that,
then you risk exposing your
family to radon,
which is a very well-known
carcinogen.
The estimates of deaths from
radon exposure in the United
States are actually quite high.
You know, 40,000 to 50,000
people per year are believed to
get lung cancer as a result of
radon exposure.
So that the comparison of
natural sources of radiation to
human-induced sources related to
national security protection,
there is some legitimacy to
that and you have to be very
careful about it.
Also, the idea of relative risk.
Well, why are we worrying about
radiation when we should be
worrying about other kinds of
risks?
We'll see that with respect to
pesticides,
where you find,
say, the car manufacturers
concerned about the emission
technology requirements under
the Clean Air Act for tailpipe
emissions.
And they point to other
sources, other critical sources
of human exposure to air
pollutants, such as power plants
or incinerators.
So this idea of risk comparison
really was well honed in the
1940s and 1950s by the Atomic
Energy Commission.
In that case,
the concern was to express the
risk relative to
misunderstanding the
implications of nuclear war and
not being able to protect the
public from excessive patterns
of exposure.
That played out by the way in a
variety of pretty unusual ways
so that many people in the 1950s
built fallout shelters in their
backyard.
My neighbors did it,
my family never had the means
to do it.
But my neighbors had these
concrete buildings that they
built underground.
They looked a lot like
basements.
And they would store water and
food and they would practice air
drills, where they would run
down into the basement.
And this was especially
important during the Cuban
Missile Crisis,
where we came the closest that
we ever have to nuclear war.
So the idea of how long do you
have to stay in the shelter to
protect yourself?
Well, you wouldn't know that
unless you had done these
atmospheric tests and you
understood how the
concentrations diminished over a
certain period of time.
So the idea of relative risk
also deserves merit.
This is also an interesting
time when the first
environmentalists had formed
their organizations back in the
1940s and 1950s.
They tended to be medical
doctors, the very first
environmentalists.
And one of the interest groups
that you recognize today is
Consumers Union that produces
Consumer Reports
magazine,
it compares product quality and
often environmental or health
claims of products.
So Consumers Union was very
active in collecting milk,
in this case from forty-eight
cities around the world.
No one talked about human milk,
and I found this to be quite
fascinating.
So for the entire decade,
no one spoke about oh,
well, if it's getting into
cow's milk, why isn't it getting
into human milk?
If it's getting into human
milk, what's the capacity to be
transferring these radionuclides
across generations via breast
feeding?
Well in part,
I think it was a shyness,
a reluctance to talk about
breastfeeding in public,
which was common at the time.
But it was clearly an issue
that the Atomic Energy
Commission had recognized.
And I found a document,
it was a document that was
declassified that was produced
in 1952 that demonstrated quite
clearly that the Atomic Energy
Commission had made the
connection like that.
It's in cow's milk,
it's going to be in human milk.
We know that these compounds
are capable of causing mutations
in genes and some of those
mutations are inheritable,
they can be transferred across
generations,
in addition to the fact that
we're exposing the next
generation via breast milk,
in addition to infant formula
in milk and other parts of a
small child or an infant's food
supply.
Also, the group SANE became
famous at this point in time,
a group that was politically
active to protect pregnant
women.
And this history is the first
history in the twentieth century
where children's health became a
logic for a stronger set of
regulations and rules relative
to emitting something that could
be thought of as dangerous to
the atmosphere.
So gradually,
by the end of the decade,
the Atomic Energy Commission
recognized that strontium-90
accumulated in soils,
it accumulated in foods,
it accumulated in kids.
They knew how to calculate what
the cancer risk was because they
understood the dose-response
relationship.
So they were basically sitting
on a gold mine of knowledge that
they had kept from the public as
best they could during this
period of time.
So here's a list of sixty years
of experimentation with nuclear
weapons, forty-three years,
forty-five years of
negotiation.
And you see the Antarctic
Treaty, the agreement not to
conduct the testing in the
Antarctic.
This is common heritage for all
of mankind, so to speak.
You see the Hotline Agreement.
Before a nuclear war was
initiated, there was an
agreement to call up the Soviets
and try a last-minute attempt at
negotiation.
The Limited Test Ban Treaty
that I just described,
the Outer Space Treaty,
the Seabed Treaty,
it's not legal to conduct
experiments in the seabed.
So that common property around
the world is now protected by
international treaty.
However, the United States is
testing at a rate that has never
been less.
The testing,
however, the majority of it is
underground.
And I'll show you a clip next
week of some underground tests
that created earthquakes in
different parts of the world,
particularly in Alaska.
And we also see a very curious
effect where these former
testing sites were eventually
translated into fish and
wildlife reserves.
So that's another interesting
thing to try to explain.
And I'm going to close today
with one more thought for you.
This entire story unfolded
between 1945 and 1963.
The Environmental Protection
Agency was created in 1970 and
the Safe Drinking Water Act was
created in 1976.
So there was absolutely no
protection, there was no
monitoring of public water
supplies through this entire
period of time.
The Clean Air Act was not in
existence, so that there was no
protection against the
radionuclides as air pollutants
or air contaminants.
And finally,
in 1976, the Environmental
Protection Agency set an
acceptable radioactivity limit
for drinking water of 1
millisievert,
or that can be translated into
0.1 rem per year.
How about radionuclides in food?
One would think that this
history would provide a very
good logic for establishing
limits for radionuclides in
food.
But as the Chernobyl event in
1986 unfolded,
we realized that we were not
alone in not having any sort of
limits for radionuclides in
food.
Neither did any of the European
Union nations,
so trade was completely
disrupted, tens of billions of
dollars of food was lost
following the Chernobyl event
because Italy had one standard
for acceptable contamination,
whereas Germany had another.
All the nations had different
standards.
But just keep this in mind,
that the United States still
has no maximum permissible
limits.
The take-away point here,
simply when secrecy is combined
with the absence of
environmental and health
surveillance,
the public opinion and politics
favor the development of
hazardous technologies.
In this case,
this knowledge was controlled
by elites and then released
selectively to an unknowing
public in an attempt to
encourage them to favor
continued atomic weapons
testing.